Speaker 1: The coronavirus and the onslaught
that has been foisted upon the American people
and indeed the world has really laid bare
some very sinister aspects of the Republican
Party that they have completely jettisoned
any concern for the American people and the
health and welfare of them, even their constituents,
this beating the drum of self-reliance and
pulling yourself up by your bootstraps and
personal responsibility while romantic to
Republicans.
Doesn't play when we're talking about an invisible
virus that can spread without anybody knowing
it.
So it's not like a helmet law when you ride
a motorcycle, that if you crack your head
open and spill your brains onto the interstate,
you're only hurting yourself.
They can't make that argument.
Ayn Rand nonsense only goes so far.
But when you try to practically apply those
ideals to a pandemic, they fail.
Let's talk about Ted Cruz in an appearance
he made on Fox News on Hannity show, really
extolling the virtues of no mandates for anything.
Watch this remarkable B.S.
Speaker 5: In a time of crisis, people's characters
revealed and the character of Democrats, whether
it is Joe Biden, whether it is Andrew Cuomo,
whether it is Bill de Blasio, whether it is
Gavin, Gavin Newsom, the character from their
perspective, that they do not respect your
liberty.
They do not respect your right to make your
choices about your health care, about your
children, about your lives.
My view is very simple.
There should be no mandates, zero concerning
covid.
That means no mask mandates, regardless of
your vaccination status.
That means no man, no vaccine mandates.
That means no vaccine passports.
And I've introduced legislation, a bill to
ban vaccine passports.
This week, I'm introducing a bill to ban vaccine
mandates.
And this week I'm introducing a bill to end
mask mandates.
Now, that doesn't mean, as the media likes
to characterize, that I'm opposed to vaccines.
I actually think vaccines are terrific.
I've taken the vaccine.
My family's taken the vaccine.
But I believe in individual choice, individual
responsibility.
You can make the choice for your family.
These mandates are coming.
And as you noted a few minutes ago, talking
about Dr. Fauci, what they're talking about
is political.
It's not tied to the science.
Speaker 1: It is political.
Now, Ted Cruz, because of you, because of
your.
Colleagues, your Republican goofball colleagues
who have made this political and it is remarkable
to me, Senator Cruz, that you list all of
these people that you act like are are not
concerned about Americans liberty or lives
or health or welfare or well-being.
And it's all Democrats.
You name No one on your side, the bomb throwers,
the Jim Jordan's, the the the Holly from Missouri.
The encouragers of insurrectionist, you didn't
name anybody there.
But to to pooh-pooh mandates, mask mandates
that absolutely curb the transmission of the
virus, without a doubt fact.
Ta ta, in one breath, talk about that, you
got the vaccine and it's it's safe and it's
good, but also say but no one should be forced
to get it.
The reason we're in a position to even talk
about having to mandate vaccines is because
you have vilified and demonized the giving
of the vaccine, so much so that there are
millions of Americans, many of whom are in
a very peculiar area of the country, where
this kind of recalcitrance is common in the
south.
And you've you've ginned up fear.
All couched in personal responsibility, all
all couched in Mau Mau Mau Mau libretti.
It is nonsense.
And it is nonsense, because if you go to the
grocery store and you've refused to get the
vaccine and you're asymptomatic for the coronavirus
and you pass it on to someone who is who is
immunocompromised and unable for valid medical
reasons to get the vaccine, and you give them
covid and they die, your rights do not exceed
do not extend beyond where you can swing your
arm.
Have you heard that before?
Ted Cruz.
This is dangerous.
This is disgusting and this is political,
that's all.
This is from Ted Cruz.